the real-life exploits of Leonidas of
Sparta and his 300 warriors at
Thermopylae have given rise to the myth
of the Spartan super hero the supremely
disciplined man a few words who had a
body of Steel could endure any hardship
and would fight to his last breath
such men really did exist and chief
among them was Leonidas the Spartan king
who defines the might of Persia saving
Greece from annihilation
in this week's biographic Sui discover
the real-life Leonidas
[Music]
Leonidas was born around 540 BCE in the
Greek city of Sparta at that time Greece
was made up of hundreds of city states
of which Athens and Sparta with the
largest Leona das's father Alexander T's
was the king of Sparta for the Greeks
warfare was the supreme statement of a
citizen this is what made a man a man
and gave him his right to be a part of
his city every Greek in every city-state
was obliged to military service from the
age of 20 until the age of 45 in order
to prepare for that life boys were put
into a military training camp known as
the ago gay from the age of seven
there was only one exception to this
compulsory military service the
firstborn son of the king of each
city-state his upbringing would be
focused on grooming him for the power
that he would inherit on his father's
death
Leonidas however was the third son of
Alexander teased his older half-brother
Kalama nursed the first was first in
line to be the next king of Sparta as a
result Leonidas spent his formative
years learning how to be a Spartan
warrior between the age of 7 and the age
of 12
Leonidas underwent a training regimen
along with a group of other boys under
the supervision of a warden who was
called the peda Nomis the literal
translation of this is herder of boys
this was a highly respected Spartan
drawn from the highest social class his
Authority allowed him to punish anyone
who misbehaved and to this end he was
accompanied by a whip-wielding squad of
youths who were ready to mete out his
punishments as the system was designed
to produce effective warriors great
emphasis was placed on a
rough-and-tumble lifestyle the boys were
divided into bands and they chose as
their leader the best fighter meanwhile
the indominus would keep a close eye on
their antics meeting out punishment to
anyone who got out of line spartan boys
in the Agoge were not permitted to wear
shoes it was believed that leaping
jumping and running were accomplished
more swiftly in barefoot the boys were
also allowed just one cloak throughout
the year this was designed to force them
to grow accustomed to sweltering summers
and freezing winters making do with what
little covering they had food for the
boys was strictly rations on the belief
that a lean hungry man fights far more
effectively than a fat satiated one also
being able to
a long time without food would make for
a better prepared warrior theft was also
severely punished and less it involved
the stealing of food the logic behind
this was that by learning to pilfer food
the boys would be practicing the skills
of foraging that would be needed when on
a military campaign as well as their
training to become warriors the boys
were also taught to read and write in
fact the Spartans gained a reputation as
men of learning who loved music poetry
and dance the age of 12 was an important
watershed year in the life of a young
Spartan he was now placed in a band of
about a dozen of his peers in order to
live under the headship of one drawn
from his ranks this was the earrin or
prefect the one chosen was the smartest
the most battle-ready and cunning though
there is no record that Leonidas was put
in this position it is quite likely that
he being the son of the king and given
the future battle prowess that he
displayed did indeed serve as an errand
during his teen years the other boys had
to give their absolute obedience to him
they were to act as his servants
collecting firewood and fetching
vegetables using their thieving skills
also at the age of twelve Spartan boys
were taken under the wing of an Erastus
or admirer to receive a form of
mentoring whereas another Grecian
city-states this relationship was a
sexual one this was not the case in
Sparta desire for the body rather than
the soul of a boy was considered to be
the height of shame at the age of 18 the
Spartan youth became a mullerian a title
which means he is nearly an earring his
military training was now stepped up as
he came close to entering military
service and so already by the age of 20
Spartan society had molded Lee honored
us into an agile battle ready military
machine full of self-confidence
discipline and a killer instinct he was
ready to make his mark on the field of
battle the ominous had trained to be a
hoplite warrior hoplites were experts in
using the short iron sword and round
shield and spear they fought in a tight
phalanx formation in which they would
approach the enemy with the shield
overhead to form a tortoise like shell
in order to defend themselves from
oncoming arrows just as Leonidas was
about to enter military service news
reached him that his father the King had
died his brother
therefore inherited the throne so while
one brother took on the mantle of
supreme
over the city state the other inherited
the role that he had been given his
entire life that of a Spartan warrior
the Spartan army was divided into age
groups spanning 10 yes within these
divisions the basic grouping of men was
into mess groups of about 15 men it was
with these men that Leonidas lived
during his 20s it was also around this
time that Leonidas married the daughter
of his half-brother she was named Gorgo
and was by all accounts a beautiful and
politically astute woman after a few
years they had a son who they named
cleombrotus
[Music]
by 490 BCE things were not going well
for Liana das's older half-brother over
the last three years Grecian city-states
had one by one succumbs to the invading
Persians the capitulation of these
powers was a source of outrage to the
proud Spartan King and in 491 he
attempted to overthrow a neighboring
king who was about to concede the
Persians but when their Kings plans to
oust a duly appointed fellow King were
revealed the people of Sparta were not
happy and klymenos was forced to flee
the city he then set about gathering a
formidable army in the surrounding
territories wisely the Spartans allowed
him to return but believing that the
king had gone insane hadn't thrown into
Chains
apparently this order was carried out on
the direction awfully onerous Pym honors
was placed under the guards of the helot
slave class the imprisoned King managed
to persuade one of his captors to lend
him his dagger with that he apparently
committed an appalling sort of Harry
Caray slicing himself into pieces from
his feet upward when clear Moniz had
taken the throne thirty years previously
his half-brother dorias who was older
than Leonidas was incensed that the
throne had passed him by finding it
impossible to remain in Sparta he
attempted to establish a colony in
Africa when this failed he went to
Sicily where he ultimately met an
untimely death and so it was that on the
death of clear manners in 1490 Leonidas
was the next in line for the throne
[Music]
immediately upon ascending to the throne
Leonidas was thrown into the heat of
conflict for years the Persians had been
threatened in Greece and now the
situation was at a critical point swift
action was needed and Leonidas proved to
be the right man to deliver it the goal
of the Persians was the absolute
subjugation of Greece they already ruled
over a number of Greek cities on the
coasts of Asia the continued existence
of other Greek city-states was a beacon
of light for those already engulfed by
the Persians making them dream of
Independence this was simply not
acceptable to the Persian King Xerxes to
crush all Grecian resistance Xerxes and
gathered together a massive force
consisting of 1207 warships and as many
as 1.7 million warriors in stark
contrast the Greeks were badly disunited
of more than 100 city-states only
thirty-one had agreed to stand and fight
against the Persians the kings of these
thirty-one states met and swore an oath
to fight the Persians and to punish any
cities that went over to the Persian
side still with the key states of
Thessaly and by OTO supporting Persia
there was no active resistance to the
invaders right down to the city of
Athens the Spartans had taken on the
mantle of leadership in the resistance
the city was recognized as being in a
position of moral political and above
all military preeminence in all of
Greece under Leonidas the Spartans were
absolutely determined to fight in order
to conquer or die the alliance with
other resisting city states allowed
Leonidas to put around 60,000 men into
the fields King Xerxes of Persia
believed that his overwhelming
superiority in numbers would guarantee
the victory it was his strategy to keep
his naval fleet and his infantry closely
connected the infantry thus marched
along the shore and the Persians even
dug a canal through mount athos to allow
the ships to stay close when the army
got inland by August the 18th 480 Sexy's
had overrun Macedonia Thessaly his army
now had arrived at the place they called
Thermopylae a narrow path between
Thessaly and the ocean the onerous knew
that he could never defeat the entire
person army but he believed that if he
could inflict a devastating blow of such
magnitude that it decimated a portion of
that army the psychological damage would
be such that the Persians would withdraw
or that not everyone was convinced that
this strategy would actually work
undermining the honored us of strategy
was the Oracle of Apollo at Delphi this
was a person who was considered to have
a hotline to the gods of Greece when the
Spartans had approached the Oracle
asking whether they should resist the
Persians the reply that came back was
either the king of Spartan must die or
the Spartans themselves must be
conquered for nothing can stand before
the mice of the Persian King each
successive city-states that approached
the Oracle was likewise given a
premonition of doom still they honored
us was not deterred he and every Spartan
warrior with him would give his last
breath to keep the Persians out of their
beloved city-state the only dissident to
meet the overwhelming Persian force on
the open fields it was his intention to
withdraw to the spot where the
Peloponnesian Peninsula joins the lands
of Attica this was a very narrow strip
of land just a mile and a half long here
he would set his men to building a
defensive wall behind which they would
fight
Sexy's as army the polling with this
plan was that it left Athens completely
without any protection so against his
better judgment
Leonidas agreed to take a small force up
to Thermopylae and engage the Persians
at the narrowest point of the pass here
the great advantage of the Persians the
use of cavalry would be negated
[Music]
the auditors decided that 300 Spartan
warriors would be selected for the
defense of Thermopylae and they would be
led by E himself so the question is now
why were just 300 chosen and why
particularly these 300 first 300 was a
manageable number for an elite task
force secondly the figure 300 had a
strong symbolic and practical overtone
in Sparta as it was the fixed number of
the regular royal body art the
bodyguards were known as cavalry men
though they in fact served as
infantrymen in the dead center of a
hoplite phalanx this was where the
commanding King would be stations the
300 cavalry men were especially selected
in an intense competition they were
selected from the men in the ten
youngest adult citizen year classes aged
between 20 and 29 Leonidas is
Thermopylae advance guard of 300 however
was to be selected with one crucial
additional criterion besides being
exceptionally brave skillful and
patriotic each of the chosen few must
have a living son this would ensure that
a son would be in place to carry on his
father's name these heirs would then
constitute an elite within an elite
bursting with pride to emulate the feet
of their late fathers in addition to the
300 Spartans Leonidas took around 4000
Peloponnesians and around a thousand
non-combatants helots it is clear for
the Thermopylae 300 were to be in effect
a suicide squad the pass of Thermopylae
has a flat plain in front of it and that
was where the Persians were encamped the
pass through the mountains to the sea
was only six feet wide at points that
the points where the pass widened to 50
feet the Spartans
set about repairing an existing wall and
making it a much more defensible
location after Xerxes vast Persian
forces arrived at the passes west and
end a three or four day delay occurred
before he launched his assault in this
pre battle pause it is reported that
Xerxes sent a message to Leo notice he
demanded that he hand over his arms the
Spartan King replied in just two words
Mahlon larvae which essentially means
come and get them yourself it was also
during this lull before the storm that
the Persian advanced reconnaissance
reported back to Xerxes the strange
behavior they saw among the Spartans
rather than being anxious of the coming
attack the Greek warriors appeared
supremely at ease
themselves with bathing braiding one
another's hair and dancing the Persians
interpreted this as signs of fear
induced madness until they traitorous
Greek in their midst informed the king
that the Spartans were certainly not mad
while the Persian spies had seen were
the actions of proud heroes preparing
themselves for their final
life-and-death struggle so the Persian
King first sent in the Medes a force of
about two thousands but these forces
proved no match for the Spartans
they wore neither helmets and/or Greaves
and their shields were made of wicker
work in the confined spaces of the pass
they were unable to take advantage of
their superiority in numbers when the
Medes unleashed a hail of arrows on the
defenders in unison the Spartans lifted
their shields overhead to form a
defensive roof over their heads the
Medes and the troops that followed them
did the best they could under the
judgemental eye of their King but it was
not enough and they suffered heavy
losses in fact losses were so great on
three occasions that Xerxes is said to
have lapped up in horror from his
specially constructed throne appalled at
the carnage and slaughter of some of his
best men behind the protection of the
refurbished wall Leo notices men
resisted by fighting in relase this
clever tactic maximized the efficient
output of their limited resources and
energies Leonidas also managed to pull
off a series of feigned retreats
followed by a sudden about turn then a
murderous onslaught on their
overconfident and distorted sewers
eventually towards the end of daylight
Xerxes felt that he had no option but to
send in his Elite Royal Bodyguard the
10,000 Immortals under the command of he
darkness but once again the attack was
to no avail and it came at the cost of
serious casualties the gone and
bloodshed that engorged the narrow
mountain pass was overwhelming the piles
of quickly rotting corpses mounted the
Flies swarmed and the stench was
palpable the battle raged into a second
day and still Xerxes was unable to make
a breakthrough by now some 20,000
Persians had fallen to the Greek
resistance and the demoralizing effects
on the remains of the Persian army was
telling why could they not turn back
these few simple rebels
[Music]
with his frustration of boiling point
Xerxes finally received his break not
through his military superiority but by
means of a traitor
Xerxes was approached by a Greek
turncoat by the name of a foul seized
from the city of malice who was very
familiar with the paths crossing the
mountain range he told the king of
another path through the mountain that
would allow the Persians to bypass the
Greek defensive position
Ephialtes offered to escort as many as
10,000 Persian troops through that path
by night and turned the flank of the
Spartans the Spartans knew of the
existence of this alternative route but
they didn't know that Sexy's knew about
it Xerxes gave the special mission to
members of the Royal Guard of Immortals
and led by Ephialtes they set out in
silence at nightfall aided by a full
moon after a heroic climbed through the
an au-pair mountain range up to 1,000
meters they easily brushed off and
bypassed the thousand fasion guards
posted by the onerous these troops were
ill-prepared and were taken completely
by surprise Leonidas has long been
blamed for not posting a stronger
reinforcements on the ANA pear path by
the morning of day three of the conflict
the Persians had the Greeks outflanks be
honored as' was now in a pincer grip
caught from the rear as well as the
fronts it is at this point that Leonidas
having recognized the hopelessness of
the situation gathered his forces
together and ordered all of the troops
except the Spartans to make their escape
their cities would need them to fight
another day but the Spartans were to
make their last stand right there at
Thermopylae all melted away except for a
group of about 400 from thisby's when
asked by the king why they too did not
go they replied that they have stayed
because the Spartans have stayed they
would die with them the Greeks made
their last stand mostly outside the
middle gate wall Leonidas showed himself
a true Spartan with the order that he
gave his men before the final encounter
this evening we shall dine in Hades the
Spartans saw their souls at a heavy cost
the Persian losses at the beginning of
day three were reportedly heavier even
from those sustained on the previous two
days the Greeks depleted though the
numbers were repeatedly drove the
Persians back then inevitably the 10,000
of the Persian Royal Guard of immortals
emerged from the rear the honor this
fought and died like a man possessed
when his sword shattered after one too
many death blows he used his hands and
mouth to inflict
injury upon the enemy the exact manner
of his death is unrecorded but we do
know that as soon as he fell the
Persians took hold of the body and tried
to drag it away seeing this the Spartans
lepton their King and attempted to pull
him back four times you'll notice his
body was dragged away before the remnant
of the Spartan defenders got full
possession of it and formed a defensive
circle around it in this position with
their Spears and Lance's broken their
bodies battered and bloodied and their
dead King in their midst
the Spartans resorted to throwing rocks
at the surrounding force of Persians
finally a massive hail of arrows was
launched and the last Spartans were cut
down perhaps the greatest testament to
the effectiveness of the heroic defense
which Leonidas had effected against the
Persians was the treatment of his corpse
by Saxbys the Spartan King was
decapitated and his body was crucified
Sexy's then went about trying to hide
the true number of casualties that his
men had suffered but the great defense
by the Spartans could not be hidden from
history the deaths of Leonidas and his
fellow Spartans greatly lifted the Greek
morale and the vital period the Spartans
had held up the Persian advance gave
time for the Athenian Greek fleet to
wreak havoc on the Persian Navy and
eventually LED TV defeat of the Persians
so by giving his life so dearly at
Thermopylae the honorless became the
savior of his people so I really hope
you enjoyed that episode of biographic
if you did there's a couple of things
you could do right now one is hit that
like button below also if you want more
stuff like this we put our brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on YouTube if you actually want to
get a notification about these videos
please do hit that Bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send
you a notification every time every
Monday and Thursday won't put out a new
video also if you want to watch
something else right now stuff from the
archive over there on the right and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]